the night king is coming the dead are
already here hi everyone it's Charlie
this is going to be my Game of Thrones
Season 8 episode 3 battle we
have so much stuff to talk about what do
we say to the god of death
not today so if you're new to the
channel we're doing Game of Thrones
videos all season be sure to subscribe
to get everything it's only getting
crazier we're doing the HBO now giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video there are so many epic things to
talk about in this episode but obviously
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet because they pulled
some really big left turns will do top
15 WTF and Easter eggs from the books
just like normal so starting with number
15 the new opening credits
so if you notice they've been changing
the opening credits based on what's been
happening in each episode the big
changes this week we're mostly around
Winterfell just to highlight the big
battle so you see the blue tiles
flipping down all the way down to
Winterfell and you see all the trenches
open up with their troops in formation
so presumably as we move down to King's
Landing in the next couple of episodes
we'll slowly see the tiles flipping over
reflecting that and we'll spend more
time on the map down there but because
there was so much battle damage to
Winterfell don't be surprised if in next
week's opening credits they also do the
same thing just like they did it when
Theon sacked Winterfell during season
two and you saw the black smoke pluming
out but number fourteen the open the
episode from Sam's perspective is
actually a brilliant way to do it it's
like r2d2 and c3po opening Star Wars you
open with like the lesser characters and
you get their perspective because he's
freaking out his hands are shaking and
all the troops are marching by everyone
is in battle mode you get the big white
shots that we saw on all the trailers
you see the unsullied legions you see
they're bullies does in front of them
you see the Dothraki bloodrider 'he's in
front of them and you get a couple of
different groups so they would jump
around to the different groups during
the episode and that's how they sort of
broke the battle up because they were
referring to this episode like their
version of the Battle of Helm's Deep
from Lord of the Rings the two towers
but in that battle you actually have the
Battle of Isengard happening so he would
bounce back and forth between the two
battles and in this case we were just at
Winterfell so Miguel subhanak when he
was doing interviews about how he filmed
the episode he said that he used these
different groups of people particularly
the people down in the crypts to sort of
bounce back and forth
so that it wasn't just wall-to-wall
action like all the Arias stuff when she
was inside Winterfell in the middle of
the episode was just pure suspense it
was something right out of a Hitchcock
movie so thought they did a good job
with the structure of the episode just
to keep you from getting too fatigued
with all the dog piles almost every
single main character got dog pilot at
some point particularly Brienne and
Jaime they had a couple really great
moments fighting together even though
the episode didn't feature them quite as
much as it did the Starks primarily the
stark characters because we're at
Winterfell it's their home so even
though Daenerys is obviously a really
really big character you don't spend
quite as much time with her as you do
with Jon Snow it's just that you see her
a lot because she's fighting with Jon
Snow and dro Khan regal but basically
the different groups you have are you
have sir Davos sort of off by himself
but he's kind of briefly with Arya for a
little while you have Sansa and Arya but
then Sansa goes to the crypts and she's
with Tyrion and Varys Gilly and little
Sam for the rest of the episode like I
said Jon Snow and Daenerys flying around
overhead with Drogo and reg all
throughout the episode thankfully they
both survived none the worse for wear
even though they both go down at various
points they really wanted you to wonder
if they were going to another one of
the Dragons Brienne is with pod Jaime in
the Knights of the Vale or at least they
start off together but for the most part
pod stays with Jamie Brienne and then by
the time they were treated torment
wasn't too far away from them but you
have to imagine that by the time they've
retreated to the courtyard everyone is
in that really tight enclosed space
surprise appearance from a very good boy
on the battlefield very prominently
featured at the line of Dothraki
bloodrider z-- with Sir Jorah wielding
hearts pain you have Barrack fighting
with the Hound torment Gendry edy and
Samwell all with the rest of the
wildlings and the remaining Knights
watch brothers I love everything about
the first 15 minutes of the episode just
the silence before they actually write
out for the first time before that
happens though number 13 welcome back
Melisandre I was a little surprised she
didn't bring any of the other red
priestesses back with her or any of the
fiery Han but I think they did a good
job using her during the episode as much
as they needed to like the episode went
down I think a little bit differently
than everyone expected we all knew that
there would be some twists but they
mainly used her for the fire twist and
to remind you about that season 3 scene
that she had with Arya prophesying all
the I's that she would shut
turns out those blue eyes pretty
important so for all the disgraceful
Shireen Bernie
you can't say that she didn't at least
get a couple of her prophesies right on
the money
she lights all the Dothraki torches up
it's this really good rally cry moment
they all get really hyped up before they
write out for the first time in
practically it's a really good visual
tool to help us the audience see what's
going on on screen because they're
lighting the battlefield up but number
12 that very first assault with the
Dothraki answer Jorah so they write out
their supercharge because of what
Melisandre has done but I love the way
you see the write off into the blackness
of night in the really clever way that
they let you know how terrible and
insurmountable the odds are is is that
you slowly hear the Dothraki cries
getting quieter and quieter and you
slowly see their lit weapons go out one
by one until it's dead quiet in black
again and you start to see them
straggling back you see Sir George shake
his head at torment as he rise by nope
not happening Daenerys is the first one
to ream out Drogo and take him into
battle so obviously that's when they
start the first wave number 11 of whites
just washing over all their forces
starting with the unsullied like this
sea of undead you can literally see some
of the whites crawling on top of the
unsullied because their formations are
so tight yeah that really funny callback
with sawn santuario where she's like you
go to the crypts now cancer dragonglass
dagger I don't know how to use it stick
them with the pointy end just like Jon
Snow told her during season 1 episode 2
so number 10 Sasa Tyrion and everything
that happened in the crypts so they
actually have some really great moments
between Sansa and Tyrion they're mostly
using them for the perspective down
there you kind of enter through sonses
perspective just as we predicted the
whites were able to tunnel in through
the side they didn't come through the
front door just like they did when they
were entering the three-eyed Ravens tree
during season six when they were coming
for him Tyrion is actually really upset
kind of getting a little bit drunk even
though it might not seem that important
that he's upset like I could offer
something I could help them do something
that they might not otherwise think of
if I were up there salsa tries to tell
him no you would just die I would die
there's nothing we can do we need to
face the truth that's the bravest thing
we can do now even though that seems
like a bit of a throwaway line in the
moment I think it's actually really
important for Tyrians character this
season for those of you that are
wondering whether or not there's going
to be some big betrayal this season I
think they're sort of laying the seeds
in Tyrion here so just think about how
upset he is about how he's being pushed
to the side people
aren't listening to him I won the Battle
of Blackwater he tells them or to remind
them about all the good decisions he
made in the first couple of seasons even
though he's been making terrible
decisions the last couple of seasons
were up against his sister in the last
half of the season
Jamie's there as well so just think
about what's going to happen with Tyrion in
the next couple of episodes
keep your eyes peeled on the way that he
reacts to all the battle planning that
happens during Episode four but I do
love the way that Sansa treats him when
they're down there joking about being
married you were the best of them the
good the bad and the ugly husbands that
she was forced to marry at various
points like she almost got married to
Joffrey's so I consider him in that
group but then you have Ramsay in Tyrion
who she actually did get married to so
number 10 though as predicted the night
king did not enter till way later in the
episode but you do see his magic early
on with that giant winter storm that he
creates to create some cloud cover and
make it harder for Jon Snow and Daenerys
to use the dragons is actually a pretty
ingenious use of his magic it makes it
harder for all the troops to see and
later when they're trying to light the
torches the wind keeps blowing
everything out while the whites are also
taking down the torchbearers the storm
is so thick that it also causes drogon
and Ragle to collide midair Jonathan
Ayers almost fall off the dragons they
recover pretty quickly thankfully the
way they lit the episode it was actually
pretty easy to follow the action even
when there were three dragons on screen
going at each other but a little bit of
that is because of vissarion's blue
flame in the regular dragons red flame
they had a really great moment later in
the episode - and bran works the Ravens
to get a really up-close look and see
you exactly what he's doing and you get
a really cool perspective shot of him
reaching out almost as if towards you
reaching out towards camera but really
he's reaching out to command the whites
we didn't quite get the wizard battle
between the knight King and brand that I
was expecting this episode but they did
share a really interesting moment right
before he was by Arya that I'll
talk about when we get later on my list
obviously that much bigger stuff is much
lower on my list but number 8, 15
minutes and we finally get our first big
character death or IP edy he goes down
saving Sam well at least he helps him
get back to the castle get up Tarly
Samwell got dog piled in this episode
almost as many times as Brienne and
Jaime got dog piled grey worm helps them
protect their retreat as they get ready
to light the trenches because he
destroys the barrier for the trench
while the unsullied
Asians are on the other side protecting
their retreat so I was like wait a
minute
is he leaving his men behind to die even
though they probably had no qualms about
that they're not like regular soldiers
they have no problem taking orders like
that but number seven Melisandre has to
light the trenches because of that
winter storm and there's even a brief
moment where her faith seems like it
wavers and she's getting kind of worried
but it's all just to build suspense as
she lights them the same way she lit the
dothraki weapons so the fire sort of
trails around lighting up Winterfell
everything about the way they lit the
episode with fire with the dragon fire
when Daenerys would ride into battle it
was all beautiful almost every big frame
like that in the episode was a painting
particularly when they had to three-way
dragon battle in the air number six
Theon tries to have that final moment
with bran apologizing for what he did
bran gives him the speech everything you
did brought you to where you are here it
brought you back home so this is
actually important for the Arya stuff at
the end of the episode - when she
the night king because think about it
this way he's basically telling Theon
that if you had done things differently
he would not be here now protecting me
and Theon is actually pretty badass
during the episode let's just look at
all the white bodies around him even
though it seems like he did that by
himself there are other Ironborn around
the godswood it's just that this late in
the battle they've all gone down so it's
just Theon and bran by the end but
before that happens there's a lot of
stuff happening with all the other
characters that I don't want to skip
over like Brienne
saves Jaime from a dog pile just like
Jaime saved her earlier in the episode
from a separate dog pile they fight back
to back for a little while The Hound
completely lost his chute when they lit
the trenches with all the dead writhing
in and around the flames just giving you
big flashbacks to Blackwater the only
thing that really shook him back to
consciousness that actually brought him
back into the battle was the threat of
Arya dying Barret points her out and
that drives them into Arya's storyline
during the episode but before we talk
about that number five the little bear
versus the giant white so if you weren't
sure which giant this was it wasn't one
one because John burned his body so it
was one of the other giants and I felt
like they gave her a pretty good way to
go out and really cool brought her back
when the night King raised all the dead
four was Daenerys and Jon Snow's
three-way dragon battle with the night
King mid air so they tried to take him
on he actually gets him pretty good
almost gets Daenerys but John and
Rhaegar managed to claw like half
of vissarion's face away which
apparently didn't slow him down at all
because at the end of the episode when
Vissarion was just laying blue flame all
over the courtyard he was doing it with
half a face I was actually kind of
hoping that they would test the theory
that Jon Snow cannot be burnt because
he's part Targaryen but they didn't
quite take it that far because then
everyone fell because was right after
Arya to the night king but number
three Arya the hound and barrack inside
the castle this is where they sort of
shift into suspense mode and Arya is
just a super creeper trying to make it
in and around the library stacks trying
to escape the whites until she backs
into the door and finds that she has to
go the exact opposite way a lot of great
kills but the minute that barrack threw
his flaming sword to save Arya from
getting dog piles I knew that he was
going down because like the minute you
give up your weapon you give up your
defense there's nothing you can do to
hack them away so that's pretty much it
for him
I was only boned out that he didn't
burst into flames when he went down you
get that very brief Melisandre Arya
reunion where she reminds her about that
season 3 scene eyes that you shut
forever brown eyes green eyes and wink
wink blue eyes which we now know are the
blue eyes of the night King in the
whites the White Walkers but mostly
talking about the night king it's
important to note though that Melisandre
did not see Arya the night king
she just saw Arya closing blue eyes in
by this late in the game once they
learned about White Walkers and whites
she'd sort of parsed out what that meant
but one of the really cool twist payoffs
of the episode was Daenerys dracarys
where she tries to give him the biggest
trocars
she's ever given anyone her entire life
and even though the night King hasn't
really betrayed a lot of emotions on his
face the last couple of seasons he looks
up at her smiles and then reaches for an
iced javelin almost getting in the way
that he got vissarion but just to be
clear that does not mean that the night
King was a Targaryen he was one of the
first men the Targaryen didn't come to
Westeros till way way later in its
history the night King finally raises
all the undead White's up just as jon is
trying to bum-rush him doesn't quite get
him in time Daenerys is able to save him
but she's in such a state of shock that
she pauses long enough for the whites to
overrun drogon and I love just watching
him freak out but in this moment he is
in fight-or-flight mode he just
completely flips his shit fly
into the air and is shaking all over
trying to get them off leaving tenaris
by herself but as you would expect she
gets rescued by Sir Jorah who gets to
ride in and be her knight in shining
armor which is all he's wanted to do
these last couple of seasons since
coming back
number two r.i.p Theon in sir Jorah as
they both go down I love the way that
they sort of took a lot of the sound out
of the last bit of the episode and they
have that really creepy somber music as
it seems like all hope is lost the night
King in his white Walker generals are
flanking just slowly walking up to bran
brand isn't that epic speech telling him
he's a good man because Theon knows in
his heart that he's about to die after
the night king him it almost seems
like he gives him a look of respect as
he walks closer to bran
but while this is all happening you also
have sir Jorah just taking hit after hit
for Daenerys so it was pretty clear that
he was going to go down even if it wasn't
going to happen till later in the episode
number one of course Arya Stark for the
win MVP of the episode the night
king with the Valyrian dagger with
almost the same type of trickshot that
she got Brienne with dropping the knife
from one hand to her lower one who hears
surprised that they killed the night
king halfway through the season I did a
video yesterday about how Cersei is
probably the bigger villain of the
season than the night king for kind of a
reason like this I wasn't totally
positive that they would him in
this episode but I knew that he would be
dead before the finale I knew we weren't
going to go into the last couple of
episodes with him still being alive I'll
talk a lot more about Cersei when I post
my episode 4 trailer video tomorrow so
just look out for that but how about the
look at the Nike and brand share with
each other before he's getting ready to
him it's almost like they know each
other like oh you're the person that
I've been seeing in all my visions this
whole time what do we say to the god of
death not today
confirm dead or sir Jorah beric
Dondarrion edy
kono who was the leader of Daenerys
Dothraki bloodrider 'he's the little
bear and even though ghost i don't think
is dead he's unaccounted for at the end
of the episode everybody let me know
what was your favorite moment from the
episode or if you have any big questions
post them in the comments I will be
doing a Q&A later this week but my
episode 4 trailer video will post on
Monday where you wait for everything
click here for my video about why Cersei
is the bigger villain of this season and
click here for my Game of Thrones season
8 episode 2 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!